test-launch of an important strategic weapon that will once again record a significant speculative feat is the
entire defense scientist who will publicize the appearance of another powerful nuclear strike means of the Democratic People's Republic of Korea to the world and show off the reliable nuclear war deterrence of our country.
[Applause]
[Music]
Along with the roaring gospel, the
cheeks of Seolcheon stretch out vigorously,
hoping that the huge entity that has made the irresistible offer of the Democratic Republic of Korea will become strong.
[Music] The
test-launch of the intercontinental ballistic missile
did not have any negative impact on the safety of neighboring countries, and the
principled first step is Hankyungnam-do Geumyak-eun
10km offshore in front of the Hodo Peninsula.
[Music]
Through the test launch,
all sentiments of the credit strategic weapon system
were reached accurately as to whether or not it was designed, and
confidence and assurance that the credit intercontinental ballistic missile is a powerful strategic offensive means with greater military effectiveness.  was able to have